and then the young boy that never walks
is how old he today he walks he's - so
huh no no you think now he never puts
him down he's always on his back Ellen
DeGeneres jokingly shames her guest
co-host Ashton Kutcher on her show for
shame no this was so cute Ashton and
Mila and Ellen and Portia are neighbours
and Ellen notice that whenever Ashton -
Mila walked by their house with her two
kids their four-year-old daughter Wyatt
is on foot but two-year-old Dimitri is
always on his back and like a backpack
contraption and now Ashton is super
self-conscious about it
take a look I now have a complex about
this because I have I have this like one
of those like hiking backpack things
that I put him in the hiker to go down
the beach so he'll so we can actually go
down the beach otherwise it's like a
whole wrangling session with the kid and
then you came out and you were like Oh
does he walk and I was like yeah see
what he was I had seen it five times as
you never seen okay so now I take him
out of the thing like once we get to
like purview of your house and I'm like
go go go I can't you've got one little
sucker
so Ashton is the best he always is so
fun and candid in interviews were
actually with him on set of the show of
the ranch last week and if you remember
his days on Punk'd did you like oh I
loved Punk I loved Punk hey reuse old
punk pal
Dax Shepard and they reminisced about
their favorite Punk days I think I find
his memories when we were not shooting
Punk and we were 16 years younger but
now great in the mornings strewn area
I mean we wake up a whole lot more
chipper yeah yeah we wake up before noon
yeah yeah you know what I actually I
mean there were times when we were
shooting that thing that I was certain
that Dax was gonna get in a fight like a
full-blown fight sure and so I think my
fondest memory was like how far do I let
this go before I let my friend get
punched because he would not he would
not stop like the fearlessness I
remember the first audition Dax came in
on I was like wow that guy's got there's
he's got something that I'm and then
when we got on set and it for like in it
was - he just had this fearless like he
took it farther than I was gonna take so
you always had that was you truly the
express goal of the first season was
that I do get punched yes a in
particular this funny moment happened I
can't remember if it's in the episode
but you he could hear everything that
was going on inside of this house and he
tells me in my ear he just said to
Jessica I think I'm gonna have to fight
this guy to get him out of my yard so I
immediately walk up to the front door
knock I'm like you want to fight me to
get me out of here all right now I'm
gonna go find old episodes of Punk'd and
go binge watch right now I'm right with
you ash until next time I'm a - Carlson
and I'm at Kourtney underscore tez and
I'm Luke oh yeah let's go let's go